hey guys i'm here with you Caro Nakamura
so first question if this was your
birthday when you have won the game no I
mean I think pretty much from the start
LaVon womp you know surprise me in the
opening and I didn't didn't respond I
guess the best way perhaps because it
felt like somewhere in the middle game
which is kind of drifting and moving
pieces essentially without without a
clear plan and then eventual I was able
to find find this idea of [ __ ] before
if I didn't come this I think I would
have just kept drifting and probably
lost the game but fortunately I found
this [ __ ] before there should be one
idea and after that it was pretty close
to even I would say I'm you and LaVon
were just arguing about the end game
what was your discussion about well I
went to her arguing or discussing our
goings very strong word um yeah we were
just discussing a different line than
what I played in the game I guess King
f1 might have drawn the spot where is
King jutsu left some playing the
position but um I think most lines were
drawn as a matter of you know finding
finding the right idea or making sure
that the night's get exchanged so it's a
rook and pawn ending versus some sort of
multi-piece on game were probably the
chances favorite block so what did you
do in the free day your birthday oh
nothing special I've been here seven
years in a row now so I just had a quiet
you know quite dinner with my mother and
my my fiance and that's that's what life
has become especially when you in the
middle of a tough tournament like this
right yeah yeah so um if you wanna bet
and you could spend one hour with the
laptop and their test analysis of any
player in the grand chest or who would
you back you mean analysis of their
games or announce evoke openings you is
studying with Jaime matters no no no no
you just got it to search their laptop
oh oh I see the point um uh that's
that's a tough question consider who I
play tomorrow but I'll say that probably
a fabiano caruana us whose laptop I
would look at because it seems as though
his preparation it might not be the most
comprehensive but it's probably the
sharpest and best repertoire of the
players who are here right thank you
very much so Hikaru Nakamura just
celebrated his 28th birthday and today a
draw against Levon Aronian in his
in a three-way tie for the grand chest
or lead I mean sorry the London chess
classically back to you guys in the
studio